you
good night iPad a parody for the next
generation by Android in the bright
buzzing room there was an iPad and a kid
playing doom and a screensaver of a bird
launching over the moon and there were
three little nooks with 10,000 books and
a huge LCD Wi-Fi HDTV with Bose 5.16
remotes and 3d and a blackberry ringing
with mmm singing and a new Facebook
friend and text with no end and a viral
clip of a cat doing flips and the bings
bongs and beeps of emails and tweets and
a fed-up old woman who was trying to
sleep good night ipad good night doom
good night bird launching over the moon
good night nooks and digital books good
night mmm good night facebook friend
good night lolz and mp3's goodnight LCD
Wi-Fi HDTV good night remotes and
netflix streams androids apps and
glowing screens good night plugs and
power lights that guide us to pee in the
darkness of night good night buzzing
good night beeps good night everybody
who should be asleep goodnight pop stars
goodnight macbook air goodnight gadgets
everywhere